sorry morning
char
e
hey good morning welcome to the special
committee on housing uh we have three
bills planned for executive session
today um and that should cover all of
our house bills that we've received and
uh we currently have one Senate bill in
our possession but I was going to wait
until uh later to see if we receive any
more I know there's a couple more
housing related Bills going on in the
Senate that I'd like to see here so um
with that I'm we're going to get started
with the
pledge I pledge allegiance to the flag
of the United States of America to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all okay so the first bill on the agenda
I'm going to call um is the executive
session on HB 12:15 and I will recognize
representative walls good morning thank
you Mr chairman uh we've got a an
amendment the correct Amendment this
time that I circulated to committee last
evening uh hopefully you've all seen it
it's uh due down from the fourth floor
uh
and basically it does address the uh
issues we talked about uh extending
the extending the uh five-year term to
10 on plot plans um and making sure that
only the zoning ordinances in effect at
the time of issuance are the ones that
are going to be used uh to issue
certificates of occupancy and uh final
completions of projects
that amendment number is 108 0 and we're
just waiting for that and uh I will be
moving that Amendment so I think once we
get the actual paper copy we can
proceed I didn't realize I didn't
realize we didn't have the paper copy I
thought you had it it's coming from
downstair from upstairs at this point
can't we just
okay yeah yep so we're we're gonna go
recess this one yeah I'm going to recess
this one I didn't realize we have the
paper copy so I'm going to recess that
one and I'm going to do um uh open it on
Open the exec on 1291 and I'll recognize
representative
Reed thank you Mr chair I move a to
pass op to pass um representative Reed
moves off to pass and further I move oh
a second which one is it I also move
amendment
number 1150h and would like to speak to
my motion
but is there a second representative
demon okay um one question I have is um
if I may this is 1291 this is 1291 I
think it's 1149
H so I have two separate amendments and
then I prepared one that combined the
both so I moved the one that combined
the two different amendments and I was
about to talk about that okay because
it's titled 1292 it says on the top 1292
oh
wow that's myus that is a typo
and I don't have the amendment the new
Amendment at all they are moving down
the line I believe oh
okay um so that is a typo uh from OS
because that is not the correct bill but
I I would still like to speak to the
amendments in concept okay go ahead so
uh last time uh when in our discussions
we talked about the one Amendment um
that I brought forward that you have
from last time which changed we had
talked about this last year in our
multiple discussion sessions uh about
what parking requirements should be
required on or towns would be able to
require on an
Adu and most of the committee to my
recollection was in favor of one parking
spot per unit um in an attempt to get
the entire committee into consensus uh
we uh changed that to allow one per
bedroom however we ended up not getting
full consensus on the bill anyway and in
order to keep this bill in line with the
bill that we just passed which would
only require one parking spot per
dwelling or allow a town to only require
one parking spot per dwelling I've
changed that back to one parking spot
per unit rather than per bedroom and if
you think about we talked a lot about
well who is needing a parking spot if
you have two bedrooms very likely very
frequently rather a lot of that we're
intentionally trying to make these adus
larger so that they can be long-term
kind of family-based housing options for
people and so if you have kids they are
likely not driving um so uh that made a
lot of sense and in fact towns aren't
not um don't always and usually don't
require even one parking spot per
bedroom on a stick built single family
house so it seemed really uh over
burdensome to allow them to require one
per bedroom uh on an Adu so to keep it
in line with the bill that we just
passed um and for all the reasons I just
mentioned um I have the one amendment
that changes it back to one per unit
further and this will be the language in
the amendment 1149 which should have
just been passed around so this is the
second uh concept of an amendment we as
a committee just passed um a a bill kind
of um showing our support for the for
having options of manufactured housing
the current Adu law says that adus um a
municipality May prohibit accessory
dwelling units associated with multiple
single family dwellings attached to each
other such as tow houses that makes
perfect sense you don't want two adus
per townhouse in a that just then you
with like 12 units um and then it says
and with manufactured housing and so I
struck that and it it looks like a big
Amendment because it's duplicating the
entire paragraph but the only change is
on line 16 where the strike through and
with manufactured housing and the reason
um other than our committee's clear
conceptual support of increasing
opportunities with manufactured housing
um it really doesn't make sense to deny
an Adu associated with a single
manufactur housing uh unit on its own
land because right now for example a
house a stick built house can have an
Adu that is a manufactured uh house but
a manufactured house can't have a stick
built even though the stick built would
be smaller than the then the other way
around in either case you would have one
stick built and one manufactured house
on a property but we allow One Direction
and not the other direction didn't
really make much sense if that is a
manufactured house we we've spoke at
length about how the quality of
manufactured housing not only has come a
very long way but in many cases the
modern manufactured housing is actually
better quality than a lot of the stick
builts available that it really doesn't
make sense to unfairly penalize people
who have chosen a manufactured house for
cost and quality both by prohibiting
them from having an ad associated with
their home so uh for that reason I just
struck through and with manufactured
housing and uh and there you have it I
did reference the RSA 674 I went and
looked that up and it was just the
definition of manufactured housing it
wasn't specific to like on its own land
or anything so the amendment that is
improperly numbered which I will get
corrected uh combines those two concepts
in one yeah and and I'm I don't think we
need to because it changes the same
language we can adopt that Amendment
onto the we can adopt I've been told we
can and the reason I created the third
one we can adopt both separate
amendments uh separately and then OS has
to prepare a combined Amendment and then
we have to adopt that so um that's why I
went ahead and tried to have it prepared
ahead of time for the the speed and and
convenience of the committee but
apparently my my efforts
failed okay there are there comments on
this amendment represent mcon thank you
going to your just turn your mic on
thank you and going to your Amendment uh
1149 and the last discussion you just
just
had uh starting on line 15 M
municipality May prohibit accessory
dwelling you associated with multiple
single family dwellings attached to each
other such as tow
houses did did that also say at the time
and manufactured housing or are you
bringing are you now saying that it's
okay by right to do it in manufactured
housing the existing so everything
that's not bold in this is existing law
the existing law prohibits a allows
municipalities I should say to prohibit
adus associated with single family uh
dwellings attached to each other such as
tow houses that makes a lot of sense
because if you have like a fourplex then
every single one of those units were to
have a right to two adus you would be
kind of getting into crazy territory um
so that was fine but the existing law
also prohibits adus associated with
manufactured housing and um if a we
heard a lot lot of testimony about how
manufactured housing has come a lot a
long way and is better quality and it
doesn't make sense to penalize someone
who has bought manufactured housing on
their own land on a foundation just like
anything else um and by prohibiting them
from having an Adu that did not make
sense uh the all the other restrictions
on adus would apply so they would still
have to uh the town would allow be
allowed to require that one of their two
if they had two adus one of them would
be attached um um all of the other
things would still apply we're just not
unfairly penalizing people who happen to
have a manufactured home on their own
land rather than a stick built on their
own land and as I said it doesn't make
sense because right now if you have a
stick built you can have a manufactured
home as your Adu but if you have a
manufactured home you can't have a stick
build as your Adu even though in both
situations you would end up with one
manufacturer and one stick built on the
same piece of land so uh that's why I
put that
in follow Struck it out thank you
representative and that's a wonderful
conversation just bring I just want to
bring you back to my
question so is are you now
permitting the Adu to be built on
because I see the line crossed out with
manufactured housing is that what you're
attempting to do okay so can I follow up
with one last
question so I wouldn't have a problem
with a private subdivision a private
piece of land that has a manufactured
house I don't have a problem with that
that's that's good my question comes and
maybe perhaps it would go to well I'll
ask you
first in a manufactured home
park this could had this could have
horrible
consequences so explain to me how you're
making this known that manufactured
housing parks are excluded or are are
you trying to keep them included in your
piece of legislation thank you my
understanding and the reason I didn't
parse it out is that parks and
subdivisions can have their own rules
beyond what the town can do um I would
like to call upon the chair to ask Mr
Frost to come up and verify that but
that is why I did not go into detail
because I do agree with you that in many
of these Parks the lots are too small
and having two adus would be onerous for
each manufactured housing uhit but
having said that I am of the
understanding that a park and a
subdivision can have its own
rules thank you Mr chairman good morning
everyone uh my name is Ben Frost I'm the
deputy executive director Chief legal
officer ature housing um to the the
colloquy between Representatives Reed
and mcon um yes uh parks in particular
Parks uh can have their own um their own
rules that would in effect prohibit
accessory dwelling units associated with
each unit in a park it's very similar to
a homeowners association which could
also have uh similar rules that prohibit
adus those those um override any
consideration of zoning U because
they're not it's not inconsistent with
zoning it's a private contract really
among uh the the uh in the case of a
park between the park owner and the unit
owners um in the case of a homeowners
association uh among the the owners in
that Association so it's very similar to
that in a um in a manufactured housing
Park subdivision and I'll note there
there are I think very few such things
in New Hampshire I I don't think there
are many communities that have adopted
manufactured housing Park Subdivision
standards that are different from stick
built or modular uh home
standards um but I know there are a
couple of them there I think uh it would
be up to the municipality to to decide
the correct lot size for that if it were
to accommodate um an accessory dwelling
unit because in many regards a
manufactured housing Park subdivision is
not much different than a regular
subdivision it's just the fact that it
has manufactured housing on it so I
don't think that's an an issue and and
honestly representative makoni you're
asking that question is the first time
I've heard that concern raised uh since
the Adu law law was adopted and this
provision of it was adopted um this uh
the prohibition against tow houses and
manufactured housing
or giving municipalities the ability to
do that was a subsequent Amendment to
the Adu law adopted in 2017 the year
after the Adu law went into effect but
I've never heard that concern raised and
I don't I don't think it's a concern of
municipalities okay so that's that's my
point and I appreciate you coming
forward so I shouldn't be concerned
about that that is my uh belief yes
thank you sir thank you Mr chairman of
course um anyone else representative
Reed I just wanted to add to Mr Fross
comments as he is well aware um in the
bill we are allowing towns to require uh
a half acre so in the subdivisions that
were mentioned a town could require a
half acre which is big enough for an
attached and one uh detached
Adu okay is there so let me ask is the
intention to move hb1 or Amendment
1150 even though the top says it's
amendment to 1292 if the chair would
prefer I mean I can email OS right now
or call Os step out if you want to
recess but if the chair would prefer we
can try to adopt each individual
Amendment separately and then try to
move forward let me ask other chairs for
guidance it's representative W there's
no substance because it's just a
technical error I think you could act on
the amendment so long as the motion was
specific to getting the the correction
made your other option would be you've
got two individuals that have accurate
numbers if you acted on them
individually it's just a matter of going
back to OS which you need to do anyway
to get them merged because they have to
be merged as a committee Amendment okay
so I'm going to ask can you resend your
moving 1150 and move those amendments
separately please yes Mr chair I
withdraw my motion to adopt 1150 okay is
there a different
motion I would move to adopt only
because it's in front of me right now uh
I move to adopt amendment number
1149 representative Damon would you like
to
Second thank
you any discussion on that I believe I
just covered this is the one that simply
strikes out the words and with
manufactured housing so I we basically
covered that and and the issues around
that so I think I'm all right unless
people have concerns are there any other
comments on this
amendment seeing none all those in favor
of the amendment is show a hands okay
all in favor any
opposed was it opposed I'm not okay all
right yes the amendment's been
adopted is there another amendment you'd
like to move I would like to move
amendment
number
that was passed out last time this is
the amendment that uh changes the
parking from one per bedroom to one per
unit 0730
0730 do I have a second thank you so
move by representative Reed second by
representative Damon
okay any more discussion on this
amendment represent VI
Kell hey
um can you remind me of the uh
bill that you are trying the bill number
of the bill that you are trying to be in
um parallelism with uh that we already
said one no more than one per per unit
or one per dwelling unit yes right yes
and
um
ah400 which if the chair wants to verify
I believe we um adopted an amendment for
and passed last time
yes
okay is this is everyone ready to vote
on
this seeing nothing is simple is pass on
the just the amendment option okay all
those in favor of amendment number 0730
please raise your
hand those
opposed okay nine is 9 to one the motion
carries the amendment's been adopted so
now we're on the a to pass as amended
motion adopting amendments 1149 and 0730
AG which OSS will put together provided
this passes so is there discussion on
the ought to pass as amended
motion go ahead represent Walsh I will
not belabor it because I don't believe
this is any surprise but I will not be
supporting this uh nothing has changed
since what I said on day one of this
committee is that I cannot with my
experience on a planning board for
almost 13 years adopt top down one siiz
fits-all state mandates on our
municipalities local control I know we
talk about it all the time I think is
critical in in in these matters that's
why even at the local level
understanding that you don't have one-
siiz fits all work there either there is
a waiver process and a variance process
once you put things in statute that all
goes away and secondly looking at just
how this would work I Mr Frost in the
past has said we do a good job in hooks
it and I apologize because I keep
referring to it but that's my closest
experience is that we do a good job and
I look at this Halfacre with with
mandating municipalities to to do this
in our particularly in our conservation
subdivisions in our cluster subdivisions
all our smaller subdivisions now
potentially um the density would
Skyrocket I just cannot see how this is
going to work without severe problems
and not and quite honestly not fair to
the people that are already already have
those properties uh if something like
this gets adopted I hope all your local
Boards of assessors are prepared for the
line at the door looking for relief from
their property taxes because once you
have a ranch that's a th000 square feet
just so you know a 2640 Ranch is just
over 1,000 square feet so we're not
looking at adus here we're looking at
homes sandwiched in between in between
people's swimming pools there is going
to be a detrimental effect on the
surrounding people's properties those of
the people that put these
in look I came on this committee looking
for Solutions I think we did a lot of
good work on that in terms of
streamlining and making things more
affordable but this I just could never
get behind and so you know a lot of
people can even the Hampshire Municipal
Association is not behind these bills
either it just goes too far I'll leave
it at that thank you representative um
representative
Gibbs thank you Mr chair uh I just want
to make a comment with regard to the
parking issue and something that was
brought up uh in our in our last meeting
um that once something was built that
increased parking could not be added and
in fact um I know that once something
has been built if increased parking is
needed increased parking can be added
and the reason that I know this is
that I live in a condo development that
was built with one parking space per
unit
and uh quite recently um within the last
year or so uh the uh driveways and um
parking spaces were resurfaced and while
they did that they created three
additional parking spaces for visitors
so this was long after it had been built
because I moved into it um in uh
1988 and uh as I said within the last
year increased parking was was created
as part of the process of resurfacing
the parking spaces so I just wanted to
add
that representative Reed thank you Mr
chair I wanted to address some of the
comments um that had been made so this
is not a one siiz fits all this is a
floor that we have already put on
municipalities to accept 1 Adu and
allowed certain restrictions and we are
changing that floor because we are in a
housing crisis and we have to too
because you can talk about like well we
like the look of this or the that or
whatever but when it comes to it as what
you know similar to the comment that was
made last time we don't have a parking
crisis we have a housing crisis we don't
have an Aesthetics crisis we have a
housing crisis we don't have a you know
barriers around our swimming pools
crisis we have a people cannot live in
this state and we can't keep people who
can work in this state in this state
crisis so it's not one- siiz fits all
there are abilities for towns to
restrict this and that um and it's it's
it it there is still power within the
municipality and if you heard um in
hma's opposition to the bill they
actually supported several aspects of
the bill because I worked very closely
with them um having said that for people
who have been planning these communities
for a decade or two decades or bought
their homes a decade or two decades ago
the housing situation looks very very
very different now very different and we
are at the point that we are going to
cause a collapse of our economy in New
Hampshire because we won't have workers
in in 10 or 20 years um the cluster
issue and conservation the half acre um
does provide those you know barriers
around your swimming pools or what have
you I mean even in that statement alone
kind of like tells like we're worried
about how much room is in our around our
swimming pool but we're not worried
about people going on the street like
that's that's a little that that's a
little telling but the conservation
issue um it's not going to be overly uh
clustered or overly dense because that
town can still require a half acre which
is not that much I want to be very clear
that the two adus does not like I think
people are thinking there's going to be
one house and then two extra houses on
the same lot that's not what this does
because one can be required to be
attached so what you can have at maximum
if a town uses their power to restrict
it you might at most have either a house
with an extension so it's still one
house with an extra house a smaller
house and 1,000 square feet is nobody's
idea of a big house um or you'll have a
house with a detached garage which you
don't know an Adu is in and then one
extra house so there's no there's no
ability or no forcing of towns to allow
a property with a house with two extra
houses or like three house structures on
on one property that's not the case I
just want to be clear about that because
I think that was a
misunderstanding but the fact of the
matter is this is the gentlest density
um of the I love everything this
committee has done we have not fixed the
housing crisis we have not made housing
affordable in this state with the
parking and the the couple things that
we've passed so we haven't fixed the
housing problem here um this will get in
the least impactful uh and easiest EST
way get to that victory garden approach
that decentralized owners are building
at their own time scale it's not going
to be a mad rush on second adus we don't
even have a mad rush on first adus
because of the restrictions right so
it's going to be gentle over time where
you don't even see that there's an Adu
going in that garage or an Adu being
built onto that house um but we are
going to provide and I think the number
was something like um and this came from
oh gosh who who testified they they
figured out the number that um might be
overtime added in terms of our housing I
think they said something like 990,000
units could be built um or based on the
percentages of people who currently add
adus that would really kind of fix our
housing shortage issue maybe not the
affordability issue but the shortage
issues certainly and affect the
affordability so for all those reasons I
think that the
the concerns that have been raised are
um not from an objective standpoint and
what's in the best interest of this
state and what's in the best interest of
property owners and I will close by
saying once again of all the um
solutions that we talk about this is the
only one that I've seen legitimately
with the ability to pass that will help
people buy homes because it's not just
renting homes that yes that would be a
Band-Aid on our housing issue if people
could afford rent but what we want in
this state is home ownership what people
young people with families moving to
this state to work in the state want is
home ownership this allows them to own a
home because they might have rental
income that helps them defay the cost of
a mortgage this is amazing we should be
doing this and so with that um I will
just end there okay thank you
representative Reed I'm gonna call
represent
mcon thank you Mr chairman
they
um there there there's passion and
there's going over the
top and um I will stand with my fellow
chair who has the right to say whatever
he wishes and not to be in my opinion
braided I was a strong yes on this but
I'm going to tell you after that I may
not hold that position we all come to
this committee from different point of
views we all came to this committee
wanting to make a
difference whether we whether we get
there as 100 or 91 or
92 um we we need to look at every
Amendment and every Bill and make a
determination and I would appreciate it
if we
could condense some of this
conversation speak to the bill and not
to the passion thank
you representative
Reed thank you Mr chair um I apologize
for anyone who felt that my remarks were
personally disrespectful or insulting um
I believe all of my remarks at least my
intention was to stay with the concept
of the bill and the purpose and intent
of the bill and the reason that the bill
is needed I don't believe I spoke to
anybody personally but if anyone felt
that way uh that was not my intention to
hurt anyone's feelings or make them feel
disrespected and I certainly believe in
not disrespecting my fellow committee
members regardless of their opinion on a
Bill thank you for that representative
Walsh thank you Mr chair well you didn't
hurt my feelings but I was insulted by
the comments because it was clear you
were directing that to me just let me
give you another perspective on why I
still have an opposition to this and
again thank you for that representative
we do come here with different
perspectives I have two when I make my
position on this uh clear I live on a
Halfacre
lot and I'm also a builder so when I can
say to you that if I took my house on a
Halfacre lot and put an attached and a
detached on it there is no room for
anything else if this bill actually said
a higher lot Dimension or a larger lot
Dimension I might actually look at it
differently but starting at a half inch
with allowing basically three units on
it I I I'd see as a disaster so thank
you Mr
chair represent VI
Kell okay thank thank you uh Mr chair
thank you
uh um for the comments from the
committee so far um my thoughts on this
this um Bill
are a couple things I wanted to address
a couple of things that that were
mentioned um one
was regarding um the concern
about
um the value of people's homes going
down if there was adus in their
area
um I personally don't I I have not seen
any evidence of that with the adus that
we have currently um and
I would I actually fundamentally
disagree with the idea that you have a
right to the value of your property um
you know on the open market but um even
even if that is an accepted uh reason
for denial of variances and stuff like
that um I still being on a being on uh
the my my Town's uh
Zoning Board of adjustments I've never
seen someone successfully argue that
their town that their value of their
property is
reduced um by any of the proposals
actually coming be before me they they
may make some
claims um but they've never actually
proven that that
is actually going to harm their value
um and and and definitely not not uh for
adus um my thoughts on the the size
requirement is is
um that with the second Adu I think
there already is a uh provision that uh
allows municipality to require
larger uh Lots but I think that the main
value in this bill is not
actually um the second Adu as much as it
is the first Adu because you can't get
to the second Adu until you get the
first Adu and and so my my issue with um
our structure in this state right now is
that we've when we did limit the Adu or
uh the municipalities right to restrict
your right your personal right to Adu on
your property um we we made
the the
uh
municipality you know take its hands off
a little bit unfortunately we did not
actually take make them take their hands
off enough that people were actually
able to make adus in the situations that
they had on the ground whether that be a
detached garage that they that's where
they wanted to put the Adu
um instead of you know building on an
addition which we've heard can cost an
an enormous amount of money or
substantial amount of money um where
putting it inside an existing structure
as someone that actually probably lived
in what would be called an illegal Adu
um in another state inside of a a a
garage that
um you know didn't have permits and all
of that stuff um
was
uh very relatively cheap to to put in
because the garage already had a heater
and the garage already had you know uh
other walls and insulation and stuff
like that that making a m uh uh you know
an additional couple of walls to put
that Adu in inside of the the garage was
um much less uh
intensive than the $100,000 that we've
heard quoted in this we're talking on
under probably $10,000 that this um you
know couple of walls some insulation and
some 2x4s and some Carpeting and you
know a light fixture um
made uh another room that I that I was
able to stay in
and so I think that in some sense I I do
believe that the um that this is
definitely more affordable and um I most
supportive of the change of um detached
to
be outside of existing structures right
and saying that um if if you're in you
know that that detached garage that is
5T away from your 5T away from your
actual living space um that you don't
have to build that Corridor in between
um to make it attached before you can
put the Adu in that you can just put
that Adu in that space if that's where
it um is appropriate based uh according
to the the property owner I I value that
I think that is the um a significant
change and I think that um coming down
from the unreasonable amount of allowing
for parking spaces for an Adu is a huge
Su
success um and so I think those barriers
that the municipalities put in the way
of people
utilizing the existing law uh is I
believe um you know outweighs any
potential
issue um that people could have with
with having a second Adu I think the
there's flaws in the first Adu law that
this this bill seeks to remedy so I
think that's uh why I will be supporting
it so thank you thank you uh
representative
Damon thank you Mr chair I vigorously
support this bill although I do
appreciate the concerns that have been
noted I think we need to remind
ourselves not only does it make it more
possible for first homeowners probably
younger folks to in fact own property it
helps elderly people stay in place
because they can put in an Adu for folks
to help them if they have care needs as
they age or to make it affordable for
them to stay where they are and we heard
poignant many testimonies from the
disabled community
about how valuable this would be to
those folks to have two adus so that
parents a disabled Offspring adult and a
caregiver for that person could all have
their separate Living Spaces on the
property I think that's a community that
we really need to be addressing it's not
small and it's not
unimportant there are other reasons as
well but particularly
for the opportunity for elderly people
to age in place and for disabled people
to live well in a comfortable and
appropriate environment I am vigorously
supportive thank you representative
representative
Gibs thank you Mr chair um I also
strongly support this bill and I just
wanted to uh go into the question of um
uh what the property owner might choose
to build because I do think it should be
the choice of the property owner whether
that owner would choose to build two
adus or something else uh the owner
might choose to build one Adu and a
garage or one Adu and a swimming pool or
one Adu and something else I don't know
what um my point is that it should be
the choice of the property owner so that
even if uh the house the original house
and two adus would take up all the space
that that should be the choice of the
property owner not my choice or or your
choice or the or the choice of the uh
zoning board but rather the choice of
the property owner so long as that
property owner isn't interfering with
anyone
else Mr thank you represent represent
berui and then represent dorenzo thank
you Mr
chairman um being a realtor I've seen a
lot of
things I remember one of the last um
back before the housing crisis I listed
a property with an in-law apartment
course we don't have them
anymore but um before the housing crisis
when I took a house a couple of months
to sell I listed a house with an in-law
apartment and I had like 12 calls on
it this that people bringing in their
elderly parents instead of sending them
to a nursing home they want them in
their home so you know they can take
care of them themselves and um there was
a high demand and very very few
properties like that this would take
care of that with the housing CR crisis
today and affordability it has another
role young people can't afford an
apartment on their own they want to go
back home but if I'm a 28 or a 30y old I
don't want to live with my
parents so give me my own space and I
think it it brings in the elderly so
that the family can take care of them
and it takes care of the younger people
who are having a hard time making it out
there and there's a lot more of them
now back when we had in-law apartments
we had a shortage of units like this we
have a real shortage of units now so I
think this would help out in a multiple
ways thank you representative lenzo
thank you Mr chair um I feel like we're
at a um an imp pass and I want to know I
want this committee to decide what what
do we feel can work um it sounds like we
we're talking about parking we're
talking about you know two adus one Adu
whatever um what's going to work where
can we compromise so that we can get
this done um I think we put a lot of
work into this representative Reed has
put in an enormous amount of work in
this and um I don't want to throw the
baby out with a bath water because we
can't disagree because we can't agree on
you know what the model should be thank
you representative
Gibbs thank you um I'm sorry to disagree
with representative D Lorenzo um but my
feeling is we should vote on what we
have in front of us uh before we talk
about whether there's a need for
compromise uh perhaps there is and I'm
not I'm not um uh putting down any of
the concerns that we've had they are
obviously real concerns um but I think
we should uh have a try at voting on
what's in front of us and then see where
we go from
there okay I'm
gonna quick thing quick um I just wanted
um because I forgot because we we
postponed this but the testimony from
the person last week about essentially
being um fearful about their living
situation um long term and that that an
Adu was essentially um kind of creating
that hope and that bridge of consistency
and stuff like that was a really
powerful testimony to me and um I think
that you know that kind of goes along
with representative what representative
Damon was talking about as far as the
disability Community needing that
support um and so for th that um I just
wanted to acknowledge that was you know
just bringing my mind back to that that
testimony and it was very powerful to me
and
um I think that it was it's worth to
just remember
that so I grew up in a single family
neighborhood in conquer and it was it's
up on the east side so if you know any
anything know about conquer there's a
lot of very nice single family
neighborhood there's the conquered
Country Club um I did not live there but
like I lived up in in that area um
beautiful single family neighborhood it
was built
like um a little bit at a time and my
house happened to be the last one built
but the Acres I just text my dad I was
like I want to know quickly this kind of
neighborhood what was the acreage on our
property which is one of the largest
ones it was 32 of an acre it was a
beautiful neighborhood 32 of an
acre and you know you had that cookie
cutter Colonial houses up there um I
think that's still important that we
preserve that I I truly do I think
that's a part of our identity especially
up here in the Northeast and I think the
language in here allows that to be
preserved right because you have a
single family neighborhood with a 32 of
an acre 04 of an acre municipalities are
allowed to say you cannot do this on
anything lower than 0.5 of an acre so
the language in here allows for this
single family neighborhood idea that we
already have and like we support and we
love but also allows the freedom of a
property owner that has a larger
property they can build that and I also
want to just point out that there was a
wur article that came out yesterday
about how Dover um is partnering with a
um a bank a credit union to allow for um
better financing for um adus in
particular I think the you know the
private Market is working with the with
public sector in such a way that I think
we're all moving in this direction where
people have the right to do what they
want on their own property I think
municipalities if they want to preserve
that single family neighborhood Hood
this bill still does that um I think
we're striking a really good balance
here so I think this is a good bill that
we should vote for and try to um try to
get
done go ahead representative Reed thank
you Mr chair um the Halfacre was very
intentional as representative D Lorenzo
commented um I've been working for about
two years on this bill and in total
about four years and I solicited the
input of the municipal Association of
num numerous planners not just my own
Town's planner but Durham's planner and
it was the consensus between the
planners that I uh uh consulted that the
Halfacre was good and these are towns
that are relatively dense I also live on
a Halfacre lot and it has out buildings
two out buildings and um where I live is
not a full Adu it's kind of like an
unofficial Adu but it doesn't have a
kitchen so it's not really um but um
it's still predominantly a a wooded lot
it is overgrown and wild and you would
not know that it has all these now we
don't have adus in the out buildings
because the town won't allow that but
the neighborhood itself is highly highly
highly desirable with very high values
and I don't understand the idea of these
values going down because as anyone
knows as any realtor knows a property
with an Adu or in this case perhaps 2
adus is a much more sought-after and
valuable property the value of to adus
of course not only can you have your
aging parent or your adult child living
there but you can still get rental
income um aside from that so um as has
been pointed out quite fairly I think we
should always uh operate on the merits
of the bill I think this committee has
worked very hard over about a year on
this concept hearing from every single
corner of the advocacy World from PR
housing and homelessness issues to
builders and Realtors and pro business
people and everyone every pretty much
every corner is in agreement that this
is not just good but needed it's
happening in other states um and the um
the movement we've had from Fanny May in
particular to ensure that the rental
income for an Adu can be uh considered
in a mortgage to buy a home has been um
quite good with that I would like to
move the question so we're not allowed
to move the questioning committee I'm
going to let everybody speak first um
but if you don't have anything new to
add I recommend you do not add in
anything new anything else I going to
call a question okay we can't call a
question representative Walsh one quick
one not expecting to convince anybody
just to clarify a few things um I am not
here opposed to the Adu statute that we
have for all the reasons described on
who it can help with your in-laws with
your kids with the with the disabilities
uh
Community but in terms of um the
assessed value I just want to clarify
this I don't think that the adus are
going to diminish the property value of
the house that's got them it's the ones
that are on either side of them and I
know representative you said you had had
a case of this with an attached Aid to
you and I believe that why would you
because they're attached I see and I'm
telling you you're going to see it when
they are single family homes behind
single family homes people on each side
of that are going to be uh complaining
and and seeking relief another thing
this bill does not do it says 1,000
square ft now you would really want to
see a neighbor after the assessing board
what if it's 500 square ft two floors
high with a 1212 pitch um shadowing the
neighbors's pool and I know that's the
nimi argument but these are real things
and I guess if you haven't been into
building to see this in for yourself
what building something here actually
does to something over here I'll leave
it at that uh I just again it's it's the
it's expansion that I can't get behind
not adus in general okay does anybody
have any anything new to
add thank you very much so we're g to um
I'm going to have the clerk call the
role on ought to pass his Amendment
that's including Amendment 1149 and
0730 vice chair Bui yes representative
makoni yes representative
Walsh no clerk votes no representative
yella yes representative D Lorenzo yes
yes representative Reed yes
representative Gibbs yes representative
Damon yes chairman Alexander yes 8 to2
measure passes okay so I'm going to put
this on the regular calendar we're
comfortable with that
um yes yes I don't think I'm not goingon
to I object to it going on
consent um Minority Report yeah
representative Walsh would you like to
write
that yeah I was hoping to have him
already written before I got here when
do you need it by um so I'm submitting
all of them probably by T Tuesday no
problem but I was really hoping to go
back to work when we get out of here
yeah go right ahead all right yep I have
to that I will okay so um representative
Reed will you write the majority
naturally okay awesome so next I'm going
to um call on repres I'm
gonna open the executive session on HB
1215 again and um call and represent
Wallace
thank you Mr chairman we actually have
the amendment in front of us um as
previously stated this uh amends the uh
exemption on existing plans from 5 to 10
years
and provides a appeal action through the
Zoning Board of it if the Through The Bu
Fire and Building Code review board if
the town does not have a um a billing
code review board and uh makes all the
rules in such in place at the time of
issuance of the building permits the
only ones that can be imposed upon this
and with that I uh I move the
amendment okay uh
1080 all right so representative Wallace
you move Amendment you motion on to pass
and move Amendment what was the
amendment number again
1080h
one0 is there a
second seconded by representative y
um discussion on this
amendment represent mcon thank you Mr
chairman um if I could ask uh represent
Wallace so um I especially I I believe
what I heard you say earlier when we
started talking about this so this um
the subdivision for instance has been
approved and you're extending the time
from 5 to 10 years so uh the standards
for or variances were granted nine years
previous no one could change that if
zoning had changed correct I'm I'm in
favor thank you
sir any other discussion on the
amendment representative
yella
um there
was just kind of building on
representative makon um question I
don't I'm more familiar with like zba
because he he was talking about like a a
a variance granted would be um allowed
for 10 years and normally I believe that
variances are for two years and so um
but I don't see any two years getting
crossed out and going to f uh 10 years
and so I'm
just I wanted to get some clarification
on what
is
actually if if the um if the uh V if the
um subdivision is
approved um that seems like that would
be for 10 years but if there was a
variance um for you know setbacks or
whatever on a specific lot in that
subdivision that that would still only
be uh that would need to be started
within two years is that am I
understanding that cor we're not
addressing variances the variance would
be associated with an issued building
permit at that time
okay represent mcki thank you and I
misspoke with when I said that so I
apologize um I'm I'm just making I'm
just making sure that if this plot of
land was allowed with those setbacks and
whatever it was at that point in time
that those would be carried forward even
if there was a zoning change that
occurred within 9 years that is the
intent in the whole Genesis of this bill
I apologize for the confusion thank
you any other comments on the amendment
okay so um I'm going to call the
question on the amendment all those in
favor of the amendment please raise your
hand those oppose all right it's 90 so
the motion carries um is there
discussion on the motion of a to pass as
Amendment as
amended
okay seeing none I'm gon to have the C
call roll Vice chair barui yes
representative makoni yes representative
Walsh yes clerk votes yes representative
yella yes representative D Lorenzo yes
representative Reed is not here
representative Gibbs yes representative
Damon yes chairman Alexander yes
90 90 um I'm gonna have represent
Wallace write the report is there
objection to this going on consent
consent all right so it's going to be on
consent okay so the last bill is um we
haven't spoken about this a lot um but
we've had a public hearing on this and
we've had some feedback on it um
representative MC Williams has
circulated an
amendment um titled amendment number
1148 um
is there a motion on this bill and and
we'll discuss this thoroughly can can I
move uh a to pass on HB
1399 is there a
second seconded by representative Gibbs
okay and then I I'll move uh also uh uh
amendment to 2024
d148 H seconded by representative Gibbs
okay um so can you please explain this
amendment so and representative MC
Williams is here for support if needed
but I'm gonna let represent Vella do
it so this
[Music]
um this language seem talks about that
for two acres or for Lots with two acres
or less in size and and for at least 50%
of the lot
in the
municipality uh zone for single family
residences they would essentially be
allowed to
um allow two residential units Allowed
by
right um and then there that is you know
lines 5 through nine that's
essentially uh the main thrust of this
bill and then everything else is
exceptions um and and saying um you know
it can't require Demolition and it can't
require
um um you know if there's uh
some if there's like water issues um
that they you know in the municipality
and they don't have the capacity for it
that that some that this unit uh you
know expansion to two units would be
able be disallowed for 10 years so that
they can um address those you know sewer
and water capacity issues on their you
know
uh in their uh you know if they have a
water and sewer uh Municipal Water and
Sewer so that they can address those
um
and um yeah so I think that like there's
just a whole host of the these
um um like exemptions um and I believe
that most of these uh exemptions to the
two residential unit are are
specifically and the reason why this
bill is so long is specifically because
of people um bringing up situations
where it's not appropriate to be doing
these two
um automatically allowing the um two
residential units um and so obviously ly
these uh that those exemptions were uh
considered by the prime sponsor and
and put into the bill and that's what
you have in front of
you
okay um represent
Walsh thank you I might as well just
speak to the issues I have with this now
um first of
all um I have no isue with duplexes as a
matter of fact most of my town is medium
density residential which allows them
and we have no problems I'm specifically
just talking about the writing or the
language in this amendment which
essentially would become the bill I
guess the biggest problem I have is um
on page two paragraph 4 lines 7 through
13 um if
uh if a town does not have adequate
water or sewer capacity to allow this
development in parel subject to
Municipal Water and Sewer proposed
housing developments may be disallowed
for 10
years so you can say the 10 years is
giving the town time for a capital
project which may be outrageous to
perform uh what happens if the town
doesn't do it now they have a right to
build these things without water and SE
I mean there there's a huge hole in what
happens here and the reason I say this
these are these can be huge capital
Capital uh projects and this is a one-
siiz fits-all again to give you an
example hooks that was created in
1822 and up until last year we didn't
have water and sewer on the west side of
the river so that's what the problem
with one siiz fits all maybe it's a
small project but it could be a large
one this doesn't address that so I mean
I have others but that's that's the big
one for
me representative
Gibbs thank you Mr shair um just in
reference to the previous comment and
again I'm not um putting down the
concern that's been expressed I
understand that it is definitely a real
concern um but I I have two um uh points
to raise one is that um after within 10
years um and I'm not claiming to be an
expert on on these issues uh but within
10 years it might be possible to make an
adjustment to Water and Sewer capacity
that did not require a major
neighborhood wide um Capital project uh
the other is uh that you mentioned that
in hookit you did not have water and
sewer on the west side until very
recently um but uh as I understand it
and I used to live in hookit uh although
not on the West Side uh that people did
live there so it is possible to live
without City Water and Sewer and I say
this because I grew up uh where we had
no City Water and Sewer uh and so long
as my family lived there we did not have
it and the reason that we never had it
even when the whole rest of the 40
square mile Township did have it was
because we lived on the other side of
the New Jersey Turnpike from the rest of
that 40 square mile uh Township and
nobody was willing to uh um uh expend
the tax money that would have been
needed to drill underneath the turnpike
and extend the pipes uh out to where my
family lived on the very edge of of the
township uh so um our our family had to
uh deal with the septic system and well
uh for for all the time that that we
live there um and I I'm sure that um
representative Walsh was not suggesting
that it's impossible to live um
uh without City Water and Sewer uh I'm
just bringing this up because I have the
personal experience of living without
it representative Walsh yeah and again
I'm not going to belor I'm looking at
the language if the municipality has
proven through an engineering study that
it does not have adequate water or sore
capacity nothing's going to change in 10
years if the engineering study provided
that except you could be pushing
municipalities into spending a lot of
money
uh to solve a project the problem I see
is that the bill or the language is
silent on what happens after 10 years if
the town hasn't CED up the money to fix
the water and seore issues and
interestingly enough on the west side of
hookit the municipality still didn't
have the money to do it it's actually
the water and stores being put in as we
speak by being funded by a
developer who will get then get repaid
for the increased taxes it's a it's a
develop ER funded Tiff what could
possibly go wrong we'll stay tuned on
what happens when this one's done uh and
and I said most of our town was medium
density except the west side which for
the sore and water reasons is why it's
low density over there thank
you represent V thank you um and I find
it uh interesting that that the
representative Walsh uh focused his his
um his efforts on on this L line 7even
through 13 because it was exactly the
same same uh language that I was um
working that that raised my hairs on on
previous amendments and um and uh was
actually changed yesterday to um to what
we see here today um because of some of
those concerns uh that I raised last
week with the bill sponsor um I
do um agree that it
is silent on
the uh the language as far as you know
is that lot so we're talking about one
additional unit on a lot that already
has one unit so that would be one more
let say uh uh connection or or capacity
flow if they're using the same
connection um going through to the um
sewer and
water and it it does say that you know
the municipality is allowed to say okay
this one more um connection or one more
uh you know residential unit getting
pushed onto our uh water and sewer is
not allowed for for for 10 years and
then on on line 12 and 13 it says not
withstanding the sewer
cacity um so you might be disallowed
just based on the sewer capacity for 10
years but then once
you um are no longer disallowed based on
the sewer capacity obviously you don't
want to just say hey if you have the um
the this
engineering study that you can just sit
on your hands and never do anything
about this engineering study
forever um there needs to be you know
the town knows that there's an issue and
they need to be planning and and moving
towards with uh addressing that issue um
however uh so I I understand that there
needs to be a deadline and and
essentially saying like hey
um one the 10 years is up they are going
to be able to if they can meet the other
state requirements for water and sewer
and that may be that that that property
now has to have a
a a septic and well in addition for that
additional unit and not actually hooked
up to the water and sewer for that land
but it's still they still need to
actually S have a plan to solve it it's
it's saying that you still have to meet
the other regulations for water and
sewer so they don't get to you know just
uh you know go to the Wild Wild West
once the 10 years is up um but I do
think that this so this puts kind of
like um I think some some pressure on
the municipality to try and address it
and not if they know that this is an
issue that try and address it in 10
years and if if it can't be addressed
then the person that is is trying to put
that second unit that they are going to
have to find a way to be able to have
that second uh unit that meets the
state's regulations for water and sewer
um and I think so I think that you
know uh kind of threads the needle as
far as as um being pushing the
municipality but not mandating that they
actually do that you know complete those
uh those uh you know inreased
capacity uh requirements within the 10
years thank you um I have a question so
represented Walsh based on your
experience on planning board I have a
question regarding um page two lines 14
through 18 that says that a mpal may
deny a proposed housing development
project if the state makes a written
finding based on proponents of evidence
that propose Housing Development under
this section with have specific adverse
impact on public health so
the way I read this is would would you
be able to deny it if the sewage
infrastructure was not good enough and
it would damage the entire system and
provide like adverse effect on the rest
of the neighborhood it says provided
there's no um feasible method to
satisfactory mitigate it so like
feasible means to me like it's too
expensive it's not feasible at this time
so that's the way I read that part right
um and maybe maybe we can adjust the
language a little bit but
um economic feas well economic feasibly
but also I see like the the
infrastructure yeah the infrastructure
isn't good enough for the for the
proposed expansion well to answer your
question yes they can obviously every
system has a capacity whether it's
supplying water or removing waste uh
they're built for a certain amount of
Capac I mean cubic feet so so the
municipality could still deny now that's
what I'm reading now just to to see if
section paragraph D would
supersede number four let me read it
again well I I
see it says if the state makes a written
finding but maybe if we change that to
municipality makes a WR finding based on
you know an engineering report or
something that they
get go ahead represent w real quick if
you don't mind but I mean it's not often
and again I'm just looking at the way
this is written it's not often that you
have one paragraph Just eliminate
another I'm really looking at the way
this is written um even no if if
paragraph D could negate number four
then why would we have number four um I
guess is my it it seems
moo um I'd have to let me read this a
little bit more um again my issues are
with the way the bill is crafted okay so
I'm going to call on if possible
represent MC Williams can you please
explain um because you drafted this
amendment during session last
weici welcome thank you very much it's a
pleasure to be here and um thank you for
giving this bill the time that it
deserves to really talk about exactly
what we're attempting to do um so as uh
my co-sponsor representative yella
explained the intent is to allow allow
duplexes with a whole bunch
of ways to exclude duplexes based on
discussions that we've had with
different participants in the process
um so the two that we're really focused
on right now are on page two um
paragraph number four and then uh sub
paragraph D under four so lines s
through 18 is pretty much the discussion
right now um and I just want to give you
a little bit of background because I
think it's important to understand where
both of these are coming from so to
start with uh section four the
engineering study um this really is for
NASA I can see this also being for
hookit but um we have a lot of
representatives from NASA who were very
concerned with this bill's predecessor
which is the fourplex Bill we condensed
and came back with duplexes this year um
NASA was very concerned because of their
issues with sewer capacity right now um
and so understanding that naswa needs
5,000 units immediately but we'll
definitely need more than 5,000 units in
the next couple of years um there's sort
of this Balancing Act between where are
we going to put them and how are we
going to handle sewer capacity um and so
having met with several reps from naswa
to talk about the concerns it seemed as
though a 10-year period for naswa to
figure out how to bond and address their
sewer capacity was fair um it was enough
time for them to be able to do it um and
then going back to meet with my
co-sponsor representative yella to
really talk about well what happens if
they don't do it in 10 years what
happens if they can't afford to do it in
10 years and so understanding that there
needs to be a way for these duplexes to
still go in to meet needs demand desire
and address our housing crisis um the
idea was okay if you can find a way that
you meet state regulations the last
sentence but does not address the water
and sewer capacity issues then you can
still do it after the 10 years the way I
see this actually playing out and I want
to be very clear for the record is that
probably um someone will say I'd like to
put in a duplex in Nashua and the town
will say no we have an engineering study
the clock runs we have a 10-year clock
starting immediately after they're
rejected in year nine you're going to
see a whole bunch more people jumping on
the bandwagon saying oh I understand we
have a 10-year clock and we also would
like to get a duplex as soon as this
clock is up um I expect that Nasha would
say all right um we've done everything
that we can and depending on how things
play out politically there's one of two
Avenues either it's been addressed and
it's resolved and so we don't need to go
further or risk management it hasn't has
been addressed it hasn't been resolved
and ashaa says we're getting a new
engineering study now to see if
anything's changed or if any of the
small projects we've done in the last 10
years might change capacity they do the
engineering study and for the subject
Lots some of the subject Lots they're
still not going to work my my
envisioning of this is that would
trigger another 10year clock starting
from the next rejection in year nine
moving forward again so now we're
talking a 20-year term where the
duplexes just can't happen on certain
Lots because because the parcels are
subject to city and water and sewer
there's no way to do a well or a septic
it's a small lot it's not possible and
so therefore those just don't work um
but it's really it's really in nashua's
court to make the decision as to whether
or not they do the upgrades they can
afford the upgrades or if they do
another engineering study and kick that
ball down another 10 years down the road
so the reality is not every lot is
possible to do a duplex on and I think
this paragraph is kind of crafted to
create that OPP opportunity if it can
exist and if it can't okay we've
considered it we've run it through all
the options it just can't happen um and
it it is a balancing act between the
city and the folks who want to do a
duplex and maybe could do a duplex if
the capacity was upgraded and we'll see
how it plays out um obviously some of
the things that we do as a legislature
are really meant to be a first pass and
we have been known to come back and
change things several years later um I
anticipate that some of the stuff that
comes out of this committee may end up
getting changed a year or two or three
later because we're still figuring out
what the repercussions are um so moving
on to paragraph D line 14 this is a
separate consideration and the reason
this was in the original bill is really
about environmental factors um so let's
just say you're looking at a wetland for
example um so this was would be
something that's reviewed by Dees it
would go to a council they would
consider whether or not you can do
development in an area that contains
Wetland and they may say absolutely not
this portion of the site cannot have a
duplex on it because it's a wetland end
of story and that's the state's finding
um so if it's related to something that
the state reviews right because it's the
state making the written finding then
that's sort of a higher level analysis
than if it's the municipalities finding
I did not mean for D to be another bite
at the Apple for city of nasua um and I
don't meant it to mean for it to be read
that way um although I suppose you could
probably have NASA bring in the state to
do an analysis of their capacity for um
sewer and water I think big picture the
goal here is to make sure that a site if
it really is environmentally a poor site
doesn't end up being subject to duplexes
and I'm happy to take questions yeah
there are there questions representative
Gibbs thank you uh representative mck
Williams I just want to clarify
something because I had read this as um
the 10-year window uh would be
application by by application that is
essentially duplex by duplex um rather
than at at year nine a whole bunch of
additional Property Owners coming in and
wanting to add duplexes um because one
additional duplex might not um uh be a
serious problem even if the the the uh
city is shall we say on the edge of
capacity one additional duplex might not
be a problem
but 10 additional duplexes might be a
serious problem uh so was this intended
to be application by application duplex
or duplex duplex by duplex or was it
intended to allow a whole bunch of other
uh applicants to jump in on year nine uh
so the intent here and the plain
language was revised to address this um
it's on line 10 for a term of 10 years
after the first proposed Housing
Development M so one just one
application triggers the the clock and
so that does create a situation where
there is pent up desire and potentially
lots of applicants in year nine I'm I'm
certainly open to changing that if if I
could get some support from other
members of the committee in order to
make it more drips and drops rather than
a deluge of applicants in year9 if that
would be something the committee would
support I could I could see it going
either way um I don't have have a strong
feeling that we must allow a whole bunch
of applicants in year nine expecting a
tital wave um but in the same hand it
seems as though from an administrative
perspective if you are a municipality
managing all these applications it would
be easier to remember one date than
hundreds of dates for the time
period yeah and then you would get one
engineering study instead of an
engineering study every single time
there's a duplex application right well
the engineering study is good for the
first 10 years but then you'd have to
keep yeah it just seems like an
administrative burden but I understand
the desire not to create a situation
where you have many applicants towards
the end of the term because everyone's
kind of sitting on pins and needles
saying what's going to happen what are
we going to do if nothing has happened
yet by that year okay other questions
for representa MC Williams go ahead
representa mcon thank you uh thanks for
taking the question um I I'll finish on
on where we've started and then I have a
second question for you so my concern
when this hits the floor is I live in a
I live in a town and I'm and I don't
have sewer and water and sewer and water
could be a well in the towns I represent
could be 10 miles away most of the towns
have some Central but it's the the rural
is so much
bigger so the way I read this is I'm the
only person that thinks this is a great
idea
and I come to the town and I sayi want
this at my
property and 10 years go
by and um town of wolfboro for for a
number of years which is not my district
but very close was at capacity and
stopped all additions of anything that
that's and that went on for 10 15 years
until they finally figured it out but
I'm the only person and the town must
expend a lot of money millions of
dollars to connect to me I I don't think
that I don't think that I should be
allowed to do that by right so that's
that's my first problem can I respond to
that that's fine so you don't if you're
the one who really wants to do this and
you don't currently connect to Municipal
Water and Sewer so you would fall under
um on page two line to section two
residential units connected to an
on-site wastewater treatment system so
you would have your own septic I'm so
glad you brought me to that section
because that's question two okay section
two a residential units and I'm trying
to help you I'm not trying to be behind
here residential units connected for
on-site wastewater treatment as it's
written documentation from a permitted
septic designer the septic system is
adequate for the for the the capacity of
the proposed
development you did a lot of work you
got Dees involved but we didn't go far
enough in my opinion that should read
for residential units
connected to an to an a on-site
wastewater treatment the owner will be
responsible to have a New Hampshire
permitted septic designer provide an
nhds subsurface construction approval
for for the increased use said septic
system must be installed prior to the
issuance of an occupation of a occupancy
permit so going back to it's it's not
enough to contact a
designer the design and this is this has
been a lot of the rub about the first
Adu Bill the first Adu bill is the only
regulation in the state that says I want
to add on to an existing use I have but
I don't have to build anything until it
fails so that that got through that got
through that's been passed that's part
but I'm saying if if I'm out in the
country and I want to do it I would
agree with you but I should have to
provide everybody that documentation
that that could
happen so let's say I have a lot that I
cannot do that on let's say I'm I'm uh
I've got a steep lot I'm too close to
the
water um there are wetlands on that
property which precludes me from getting
that state approval so I can't get that
so now I want the municipality to bring
me sewer and
water I I don't think I think that's a
great burden on municipalities and I
think we're going to lose the bootes we
need in the house so to be clear to
respond to that scenario yeah I think
it's already been ruled out that you
cannot do the needed septic on that site
it's too sloped it's too wet whatever
the issue is it's not a possible
site on line8 where we talk about
adequate water or sewer capacity to
allow the development in Parcels subject
to Municipal Water or sewer so unless
your parcel is currently subject to okay
Municipal Water or sewer I don't believe
it rises to the level of demanding that
five miles of water and sewer run out to
your sloping parcel that currently is a
septic parcel because it's not subject
to Municipal Water and Sewer I suppose
we could change that to currently
serviced by if subject two isn't clear
but the intent here was never to trigger
um additional Millions to be expended by
a municipality for someone who's looking
for a back door to get their duplex okay
would you uh if I could would you agree
to additional language in line
two yes I love the proposal that you
gave me if you have that written down I
think that that's a fair amendment I I'm
open to other committee suggestions but
I think that that is very fair and
addresses the concerns we've seen with
adus with preliminary language not
really working out in the real world
okay thank you other questions for
representative MC Williams
representative
Gibbs thank you um this is isn't
actually uh a question on the um uh on
the septic systems and so forth um
although I agree that uh what was just
suggested um is probably an excellent CH
an excellent change um but I think that
there's one additional thing that hasn't
been considered and this would make more
sense actually if there were a group of
um delayed uh uh additions that would be
coming that would be coming in at the
end of the 10-year period and that is
that and again I'm not an expert on on
this kind of thing uh but if an
additional group uh would be coming in
say I don't know 20 uh delayed uh
additional developments would be coming
in at the end of at the end of the 10
years
um the taxes of those Property Owners
would rise
and might it be possible for the city to
bond its Capital Improvements on the
basis of the fact that when those
additions um were
added that additional taxes would be
coming into the
city I I do believe that that is
allowable and a city could choose to do
that I do want to draw your attention to
page two line 5 Section 3 a municipality
May charge impact fees for new
connections to Municipal Water and Sewer
services so I would expect that there
would be a cost passed on to each of
these new proposed duplexes where there
needs to be an upgrade or a connection
for the first
time are do you have a
question represent yell is that a
question it's not a question no okay are
there
questions okay so thank you
representative
um yeah
so that that's my question so
representative
coni the last day to act on Bill is not
in a second committee is next Thursday
so we can either finish chatting about
this and maybe amend it a little bit and
then we can have a quick exac at
lunch during session if you prer propose
to do that or we
can stick around here so it's up to you
up to the
committee
yeah I'm okay either way
okay any other discussion on this
amendment
enough I know representative Walsh
wanted to get back to work take that
into
account to do this I what I have to
do of course okay are there are there
other I yes
yeah
what
over oh yes that's true done by really
Wednesday all right so
we the last Daya
act last day act on house bills not in
the second committee is Thursday March
first oh hold
on last day of report is the
21st the 28th is the last day of
act so I I guess let's um let's see if
OS can get that language
quickly um I don't want to break for a
long line
I is THS yeah so
that's we'll be all right to do it
at it wasn't noticed yeah it's not in
the calendar for next week though the
Calendar's out yesterday no I can
announce an exact during
session because every representative is
supposedly
there right I believe I can announce an
exact during session I believe that has
happened how about email Mr
Mr chair I think you need to call the
house clerk
immediately yep I'm going to call it
okay we're going to recess for five
minutes
e
okay so we're going to recess um we're
going to wait on an amendment it
shouldn't take long so I'm thinking
hopefully by 125 but in the meantime the
Republicans are going to go caucus and
L300 okay
e
all right welcome back unfortunately
after recess until 1 o'clock we're
waiting on an amendment from OS so until
then we will not be um exing but we
should finish up the bill right at 1
o'
e
for
okay Welcome Back special committee on
housing I'm going to reopen the
executive session on HB
1399 and I'm going to call on
representative
yella to resend his motion on the
previous Amendment and offer amendment
number 1157 H represent
so moved there a
secondes
second it's in your email that I don't
have to redo my
document it's in our
email yes as verified by representative
makon representative makoni can you talk
about the change that was made in the
amendment thank
youed the language of the original word
just put your mic
on expanded the wording on
page
to um to uh instead of having to uh
consult with a septic designer if I
remember right I don't have this in
front of me to require that the
owner um obtain a construction approval
from a septic a permitted septic
designer for the uh property and uh
construction approval means the septic
design has been submitted to the
department and that the new loading is
under consideration they agree that they
could a new septic system could be built
on the property
um and then I'll go to my line two
residential units connected onsite
Wastewater system the owner shall
provide proof of a New Hampshire
Department environmental services
subsurface construction approval for the
increase septic loading so you know that
the lot will handle uh whatever is being
proposed to be built and upon the
Department's issuance of approval of the
septic system
operation uh so it's a two part process
you need a septic Design This is the
property and the property will will hold
it and part two is they need to build it
put it in the ground and when it's in
the ground the state will come by and
inspect it and it'll be issued what they
call an operational approval so we're
it's a it's a double check to make sure
that the
homeowner puts it in the ground and it's
approved for operation before the town
gives them the occupancy permit so it
protects protects the
environment representative Walsh yeah
thank you Mr chair and this is for
representative M thank you for that
language and I'm just asking a
question notwithstanding paragraph two
or sub paragraph two if paragraph 4 is
still
there and I thought this whole thing was
assuming that the subject property did
not have the
capability of a new septic system or
well I thought that was the reason for
paragraph 4 just because exit paragraph
two is there why would not paragraph
four Still Still kick in in terms of
responsibility of the
municipality well paragraph two has to
do with properties that aren't connected
to City
Wastewater in sewage four is connected
four is has to do with properties that
are
connected
the the sponsor of the bill previously
pointed us to what is now line nine
where it says subject to
Municipal in uh allows this development
in partials subject to the Municipal
Water and Sewer so if they're not if
they don't have sewer and water then
they would be covered
under subse section two if they do have
it they would be under subsection 4 and
then if the whole if the state finds
that there's an issue then that would be
sub then that would be D so
there's hopefully all three of those are
independent of each
other um go ahead repres thank you maybe
this is just a Dawn breaking over Marble
Head paragraph sub paragraph 4 did not
change so that's also for areas that do
not currently have Municipal Water and
sore that's the whole reason for the
term up to 10 years in the denial but it
still says that after to 10 years
nothing changed in it then then they
will be able to build by right and I
thought that's what the prime sponsor
said as well this is assuming that you
there's no capacity on the site for
personal water and Waste Systems which I
think they can do
now
right representative Wallace thank you
Mr chairman it was discussed previously
today in in committee that the subject
to Municipal wat was synonymous with
connected
to we did have some discussion about
changing that language but apparently
that didn't occur I'm fine with it the
way it is but that's subject to again is
analg to connected
to and 10 years hence if we still didn't
have the capacity and there's
no uh viability for an on-site septic
system the expansion could not be
undertaken is that correct represent M
MC Williams
I'm represent MC Williams can you clear
this up for us please and then I'll call
on the committee members that want to
speak thank you for the question um so
we discussed before the break that
subject two on line nine related to
Municipal Water and Sewer would mean
that a property currently has Municipal
Water and Sewer you are subject to for
the property you own you're connected um
so it's really a capacity question not a
br bringing in new lines so the example
that uh R mcon brought up I believe was
that if you had a very rural site and
you were trying to get the city or the
town or whatever to connect a Mile's
worth of pipe to you you could not use
section four to to demand that they
would bring that to you because you are
not currently subject
to does that clear this
up thank you it does get me closer one
more scenario though what if a
lot if if we're saying that subject to
Municipal Water means it's going by you
on the
street and what if your lot was not
suitable after perking Etc or or or to
to or even large enough for um personal
septic and water for the duplex if the
capacity is already Beyond on the uh on
the municipal end then still we have the
10 years which to me would still be
compelling to the town to make the
improvements to get that approval
there that would be in that situation
where you've purchased a lot and water
and sewer run by the lot but you're not
currently connected because it's an
empty lot right so you've applied you
want to put a duplex on that lot City
responds no we have an engineering study
that says we cannot our capacity is not
good enough 10year clock runs at the end
of the 10-year clock under this bill it
says all previously delayed Housing
Development projects must be allowed by
the municipality by right after the
expiration of the term so you still get
the hookup after 10 years but you're
still subject to State requirements
regardless of what the municipality says
so if there's a state reason for no
section D or last sentence of four then
you still could get kicked out and not
be able to so that is a piece of it and
yes in that example an empty lot that
has sewer and water running past you
would have a 10-year clock from
application once you're
rejected I'll leave it at that okay
representative
Gibbs thank you um representative MC
Williams um you can correct me if I'm
wrong but earlier I had understood you
to say that if at the end of 10 years um
there was still not sufficient capacity
uh for water and sewer for the proposed
duplex and if it would not be possible
to set up a private well or a uh private
uh Waste Disposal system uh that uh it
could be denied for another 10 years
that another 10year clock could
run so we talked about getting a second
engineering study which could indeed
trigger a second 10-year clock and and
would probably year nine when the this
municipality sees an uptick in
applications they would go get another
study because the intent would be we
need another 10-year delay I'm just
talking about a hypothetical here
ideally the municipality has figured out
a solution to capacity issues but if
they haven't this is one thing a
municipality could do is get another
engineering study which would cause that
10-year delay for the next clock to run
from the first proposed Housing
Development under the new engineering
study moving forward so it effectively
cuts off any more applicants after the
new study so we talked about the
administrative load where every time
somebody tries to get a duplex and
they're told oh no we can't we have an
engineering study administratively I
suppose the municipality could be
getting new studies every year so they
have literal 10year clocks running from
2024 to 2034 from 2025 to 2035 they
could do that it's just a cost and a
load on the municipality to keep
delaying by 10 years these waves of
applicants so there are many ways this
could play out out I think the intent
here is to at least put some teeth in it
to at least show the municipality that
the state is serious about allowing
duplexes and that you have a 10-year
window but then you must allow all
previously delayed under that 10-year
window by right there is still an
exception for the state issues so if
there's a greater picture problem I'm
I'm still seeing there may be an
opportunity for the municipality to
reach out to the state and say review
our capacity where are we at this is
this possible is this um not feasible
for us to upgrade our capacity and I
suppose as often happens here this could
be subject to a court case where we
determine whether or not it was feasible
for the municipality to upgrade or not
um I and I don't want to do that I don't
want to kick it to the courts I'd rather
have good clear language um but this is
once again threading the needle trying
to find something that can meet both
getting those units that we need in
municipalities that don't currently have
the city water and sewer to to service
those properties and also making it very
clear that you can't keep kicking the
can for 10 20 30 years uh follow-up
question um okay uh and I understand
certainly the desire not to keep kicking
the can down the road but if at the end
of the 10 years there were a new
engineering study which said that for
whatever reason it was still currently
not feasible uh to provide water and
sewer that would start another 10year
clock and so the uh development still
could not go in as of right if in fact
the water and sewer was not feasible at
that point the new clock could not the
Old Clock
can okay but the under this but the
actual development okay I have a house
and I want to turn it into a
duplex okay and I put in my application
and the municipality says it's beond our
water and sewer capacity and they get
they get an engineering report that says
our current capacity will not provide
for this so then we have a 10-year clock
and for whatever reason um the city has
not been able to resolve the
problem I would think that they should
be able to within 10 years but assuming
they had not been able to within 10
years and they then get another
engineering study can can I then as of
right um put in my development or not if
a new engineering study says it's not
feasible we still don't have enough
capacity under the scenario that you
have described you fall under the first
engineering study your clock started
well the clock started when the first
proposal under that engineering study
went in when those 10 years are up
you're allowed to do your duplex even
though it will increase capacity on the
municipality that has already told you
it can't your 10 years are up you're
allowed to but the new engineering study
is for new
applicants okay representative
Walsh which
line allows the municipality to create
the second engineering
study I guess there's nothing to stop
them in current law somewhere but I'm
just I guess my fear is well go ahead I
if you can answer that one nothing in
this law prevents a municipality from
getting an engineering study related to
capacity for sewer and water every year
every six months however frequently that
municipality feels they need to do that
there is nothing in this law that
prevents them from doing that thank you
represent
V thank you I think that it would be
just
the the um the engineering study that
they are using to dis
allow right if they're saying this
engineering study
um is the one that we I I'm I'm I think
that every single applicant from the
first applicant to 10 years from that
first application would be covered under
that um
first
uh study study and that at 10 years and
one day they would be able to deny on
upon that new study that they got let's
say in year nine but they wouldn't be
able to apply to people in year nine uh
because they are currently under the um
within the uh that 10-year window as far
as um the because all previously delayed
housing projects essentially from that
10-year window
should be allowed and under the language
in 11 and 12 and then at 10 years and
one day they could have a new
engineering study that starts that 10e
clock again for those new
people do you see what I'm is that am I
reading read more I think you're reading
more into it than what it says
unfortunately or fortunately either way
um I think you could argue it either way
uh I
think you can have an engineering study
dated let's just say the date it's
today's date okay so it's the Ides of
March 2024 we have an engineering study
Monday someone applies to do a duplex
they fall under that engineering study
okay then next month on the first of the
month we commission a new engineering
study with a new date if there is a new
applicant as of the second of um next
month then that new applicant falls
under the new
study go ahead thank you I think you're
reading into it than than than is there
because I think that the the application
is all based on the
um that
the the 10 years is based on the um
first denial so if you got a in
engineering study today that says you
don't have any capacity and you didn't
get a request for 15 years and you got
and then you said hey uh or however long
the study is is valid for let's say it's
one day less than the the study is valid
for let's say in the hypothetical the
study is valid for five years um or 10
years I I have no idea I've never seen
one of these studies so the day
before that that um that uh study is no
longer valid you get an application you
could deny based on that application
even though it's 10 years old or
whatever the case 9 and 364 days old you
could deny under that and it would be
denied for 10 years under this even
though now that study is no longer valid
because it is following 10 years after
the proposed Housing Development not 10
years after the study it's 10 years
after the denied propose um development
so that would essentially grant them 20
years even though their study is only
good for 10 years and so um I think that
it's all based on on this time frame ver
uh of the first proposed development and
the second and the third and the fourth
and all the ones that that are in that
10 years are all denied automatically or
disallowed by the municipality
automatically is my reading of this
language but you know that's so in the
real world you're going to have capacity
studies and you're going to have changes
in capacity
over the course of 10 years that's just
how how this works is that there are
upgrades to the system roads get torn up
pipes get uh replaced resized so it's
not stagnant it doesn't stay the same if
you were to commission another study the
data would be different because things
are changing with our water and sewer
where we have them and that data is
constantly in flux so it doesn't stay
the same for 10 years is my point your
your data is no good if you were
challenging it after six years or asking
for a new
study representative
Gibbs thank you um
so increasing the capacity would not
necessarily require a huge
neighborhood-wide Capital project
increasing capacity could result from uh
say the process of repairing some very
old pipes and putting in some larger
pipes that conceivably could happen and
that would change the level of capacity
along that particular Street
yes okay are we all set with
representative MC
Williams yes okay thank you all right so
is there a discussion on this amendment
it's been moved and seconded is there
any discussion on
it represent Walsh just one and I'll
keep it brief I know we uh were some are
under a lot of pressure to come up with
Solutions but I hope we're also in favor
of passing understandable law and with
the 10 of us in this room we're still
probably not on agreement of what
actually this does and nothing
argumentative but even the prime sponsor
says there are many ways this could play
out and this is all like threading a
needle so if we're going to start
imposing mandates on a municipalities I
would hope that the language we would be
telling them what to do is a little
clearer than this so for that I'm not
going to be able to support this
amendment
okay anyone else all right is the show
of hands okay for the amendment all
right all those in favor of the
amendment please raise your hand those
opposed okay so it passes nine to one
nine to Bert nine to Bert shout out all
right so now we're on the final a to
pass as amended with amendment number
1157 is that there any discussion on
that
motion who's made that motion uh motion
by representative yella and seconded by
representative
Gibbs represent brudy
yes do you have something to say oh no I
thought he was calling the role oh okay
so with that the clerk will call the
role uh Vice chair
barui Yes again representative makoni
yes representative Walsh no clerk votes
yes representative yella yes
representative D Lorenzo yes
representative Reed yes representative
Gibbs yes representative
Damon yes last but not least chairman
Alexander Yes 91 measure passes all
right so I'm going to leave that on the
regular calendar as well as I think
representative Walsh made a good point
that there's a lot of explaining that we
need to do on this bill
so too yes we got some splaining too all
right beautiful so that finishes up our
um house bills so um these will not be
on the calendar for next week I'm
assuming they'll be on for the the 28th
so I'll send around an email um there's
only two bills that we'll have on the
regular calendar at this point but I'll
send an email around who's responsible
for What on the floor if uh any of these
are pulled off consent
so with that I would like to get reports
by
like Tuesday at the latest so if you
have time to do that so representative
Walsh you have two um representative
Wallace has one representative Reed has
one representative yella has
one okay well thank you
everyone